it's an almost completely anonymous
building in central caracas but it is a
high security prison
no outsiders have ever been allowed in
here before
we've searched in our equipment checked
before guards opened the gate
the multi-story building is basically a
huge square
the staircase leads you to the only
outside space in the prison
this secretive institution has a special
class of
inmate this is where the venezuelans
lock up the
[Music]
these foreigners parade ground rituals
are not compulsory
but if the prisoners don't comply to
what is a form of institutionalized
brainwashing
then they're given no good behavior
credits against their sentences
the foreigners are praising the
revolution of hugo chavez
and they're from all over the world
they're almost all
convicted drug smugglers
salvatore cherelli is from southampton
his father is italian
he's serving 13 years for cocaine
smuggling
he admits trafficking several times he
was he says
trying to raise money to come home to
the uk
we went broke so we decided i decided
not that i decided to do that so
it was uh to get more money to go to
india because we don't have money enough
to go to england to survive in england
so we have to sell the houses here
the cars the lands and everything to go
back to europe
this is by no means the worst prison in
latin america
but for the men spending long hours in
tiny cells
the fact that they're in a country where
ordinary people can't eat
where medical supplies are scarce and
human rights are regularly abused
means they're extremely vulnerable the
prison system like everything else in
venezuela
is in danger of falling apart with them
inside
they have no communication with the
outside world
in the culture room basically the
library john tweel
looks after the prison books originally
from spalding the 58 year old
is serving 15 years caught with 31 kilos
of cocaine at the airport
like most of the prisoners any despair
has long since gone
when you've been in prison eight years
eight and a half years it's no good
crying i'm gonna
cry what would be sad to be sad i'm sick
as it is i can't it's no good
me getting down and depressed because
i'll get sick more sick soon
so it's no good getting depressed about
these things and hopefully my sentence
is finished soon
alexis sanchez is from new jersey in the
united states
a man in his hostel room was carrying
drugs he wasn't he claims
either way he's now serving 17 years for
dealing
mr sanchez wants to be repatriated to
the united states
but with relations between the u.s and
venezuela at an all-time low
he knows his case is not a priority
maybe because of my nationality
they could disapprove this is just an
opinion that i'm having it's not a fact
you understand
but we all know that in politics these
type of things
tend to happen from time to time
the venezuelan authorities confirm that
despite covid all the foreigners remain
in this prison
and are alive all the repatriation
requests
appear to be suspended but there is no
other communication with the men
and of course they have no idea that a
pandemic
has just swept across the world stuart
ramsey sky news
caracas